E aí
e fazemos muita satisfação ao fazer
ciências quando nosso descobrir isso com
uma coisa que funciona no meu WhatsApp
no organismo explicar nos diz que um
modelo passar São João lá
eu vou ao currículo esse todinho já tava
muito leilão de fazer senso vai fazer um
elogio e consciência associar com
descoberta a explicação do fenômeno
natural até energia necessariamente está
relacionado com a criatividade com a
criança é uma coisa nova as regiões
vende utilidade fazer fiscalidade
e como a ciência os alhos grandes
momentos eu era até elogios vários
momentos Caraca o soro recheio saco
antes dois dias depois que ela fez
assistiram nossa saúde e juntos ó alguma
coisa que eu vou utilizar vai na minha
vida
a energia em Rio na cidade de mudar as
nossas vidas ciganas a tecnologia e
poder de dados nossas vidas
principalmente do que nós não somente
contemplamos a tecnologia mas nós
utilizamos a tecnologia em nosso dia a
dia e assim ela vai mudando os nossos
hábitos nos nosso sabes hábitos moro
agora algumas ideias e até amigos com
nossos geramos Independentes
relacionados a
E aí
e hoje tem mais Auxiliadora seu
descobridor uma sensação de Poder Além
das quais são as mulheres puro de alta
confiança de esperança Se eu colocar na
tecnologia as esperanças dele é
eu vou fazer energia falta de boa faz
ver e satisfação não tem opção ligação
a tecnologia só aqui de com bateria de
carro no seu bolso porque essas nada
disso tem um dia em qualquer coisa que
vão ver fazendo isso vamos ver integre e
as grandes mudanças da foco nós grandes
são associadas às mudanças do século XI
ao uso que ela seja as nossas crise pode
ajudar nossos hábitos
eu perguntar para vocês hoje aqui vem um
exemplo de um objeto erótico
provavelmente vocês vão tirar do bolso
um aparelho celular smartphone
um tempo desse batom talvez você tenha
sido já era dos smartphones vão conhecer
o mundo você é
e sempre pensar como seria sua vida
sempre acesso ao Inter larga dizer o
segredo aqui para só ignorância filho
meu telefone a posição com internet só
que todas as pessoas Google seguramente
amar ler ou nossos relacionamentos esse
quantos anos diversas Quantos
relacionamentos foram aprovados a
própria receita de carne as estrelas
executadas
um simples facilidade poder fazer uma
chamada de vídeo qual que é garantida
pelas paredes mas as mudanças não só
apenas positivos
a biotecnologia feliz diluir nós as
chances das realizadas também pode ser
usada para criar uma multidão de
solitários e assim
em nossos relacionamentos próximos pode
ficar vandalismo atitudes Artes da Rose
nossos relacionamentos vamos lá mesmo
até fugir podem ser transformados do
silêncio tá pegando mensagem de hoje é
da meus preze poder de mudar a sua vida
muito espécie não teria reflexão crítica
sobre. Até energia alteram América a lei
nossos 200 com base urgente
um pouquinho da minha visão de Jesus eu
sou o professor de Engenharia Naval e
Oceânica da Universidade de São Paulo no
Jardim seu like com seus um pouquinho
mais complexo do que parques para o -
sistemas em mente alguns recursos mudou
a forma como as pirâmides com energia
que pregam Uni as pessoas são grandes
sistemas espinafre potencial de cada um
a fazer um exercício lá no curso de
engenharia de sistemas projetados
e o passo gira necessário resistir os
aspectos dessa tecnologia e são
exatamente dela os aspectos diretos e
próximos o projeto de nave por exemplo
Qual o valor que Hitler o a a gritar lá
o leite em pó combustível e vazar não de
vai viajar alguns que vai precisar
urgente Edna me passa todas essas não é
difícil trabalhar mas existem outros
aspectos da realidade mais existem
outros aspectos que muitas vezes não
sofre esse vídeo solidificar roubando
presídios podem ser explorados
se você já pedi Como funcionava as
tecnologias jogar consideração de outros
aspectos ou Marcos mas a filosofia
ajudar
e os nossos cursos tecnológicos Brasil
de falei entre os dois saquinhos de
veículo quase que exclusivamente ao
circo seguir as técnicas
Oi Márcia curso de engenharia por
exemplo éramos usar a habilidade Técnica
das realidades econômicas do objeto sabe
fazer quando você tenta trazer filosofia
a servir a tecnologia geralmente ela vem
cá
e hoje se isso acontece nas
universidades como se foram com isso
filosofia para gerir normalmente vem um
lápis ou sogra filosofia
Oi Patrícia volume valores tecnologia
que chorar deixar o projeto e não fazer
Pontes A reflexão ou ruim difícil para
mim pegar pensamentos de sabão gigantes
foram que fazer implicações diretas e
indiretas o seguro antes de morrer mas
precisamos lembrar gata rejeitar os
alunos tecnologia mas eu estava
escondido nos Bambuzais Face dela
acessível para o link abaixo vendido
o veículo não consegui uma escola de
pensamento filosófico análise técnica
Garrincha separado dentro de buscar
técnicas isso é muito bonito uma série
de negócios chegaram a uma filosofia
analítica e aplicar no ferro gente ele
te chamou de filosofia da tecnologia
sorriso você já sabe me desenvolveu uma
filosofia a vocês vão nos ajuda a
refletir a realidade
Oi Luisa Olha só para atualizar aqui
deixa eu vou explicar vou levar alergia
e imunologia
a notícia que a renda possa ser
publicada uma base neutra ela sua irmã
de saudade e você pode chegar eu vou
chamar de ações Morais a verdade de
significado de Lisboa Project nela a ele
a faça um
[Música]
o Bob Esponja só curto ou base habilitar
a verdade pode musicar precisa sexo mas
ajudar muito prático sem sair e nave
espacial 1
o favorito da tarde favor buscar por 200
dias por ano
quer saber qual foi chegar fala possível
amigos fotos e
E no caso alguma negócio simplificar uma
segue dirigirem aos fogos nossos
chegamos e chegamos ao trabalho até logo
scorro
e a esse conjunto de ideias estou
deitada energia uma base com perdido
relacionamos estilo e tecnologia e ela
lá é filosofia mais acessível ao
dinheiro e aleluia entender não corre
vamos aplicar daí ligar para você pode
eu sair do ensaio tá muito bonito com
alguém de televisão após previsão a 77
é como se a promoção Black final da sua
vida descartado descansar lá no
cemitério do Araçá
[Música]
o museu publicado sala visitar e levar
vocês vão perceber que seja enviado mas
o impacto filhote resposta
o combo dá certo se não foram
considerados progenico sobre a criação
de interação e não tomar então grossos
mas igual você identificados acessados e
avaliar o funcionamento do Tesouro
público
a cozinha o quarto a gente pessoas estão
você começa a dirigir a sorrir por uma
sua vida transformada ao redor de cima
dele arredondada algumas pessoas
significa seu trabalho sua razão livre
sua habilidade e atenção não sei mas não
devemos desprezar dinheiro preciso usar
a fôrma Negra mulher dois lados é
e vai terminar eu não faço curso vou dos
nossos lanches do dia seis anos o que eu
faço não temos uma lei de dar o
reconhecê-la muito apenas uma técnica no
mapa do baixo fora e como criar vamos ao
próximo passo informação nosso curso é
uma nossas Engenharia e
[Música]
a ouvir a música mandei duas uma nova
geração de Agentes a tecnologia para o
refletir sobre aquilo que estavam vocês
se você tá com você até hoje tem
condições de dar a saber
e mesmo assim para receber tipo existem
relacionamento é possível a reflexão
crítica da realidade do aluno e ferj
profissional de gênero gostaria de Jesus
utilizando a Luzimar de pressão ainda 15
anos 60
nós não estamos possível um Aventura O
Apoio às vezes lá calha
[Música]
E aí